The Joe Rogan Experience
Anderson is
as far as I know the only God who
successfully come back after that Shin
break yeah no one else is really no one
else was able to do it well uh didn't uh
McGregor well Tyrone spawn
did McGregor fight uh
no he hasn't fought since oh okay yeah
but Tyrone spawn he's done it yeah he he
had a horrible one against gokhon saki
horrible same thing as uh Chris Weidman
Uriah Hall same check horrible snap and
isn't anybody to come back though he's
good well Tyrone spawn became a boxer
he'll still do MMA I know he had at
least one MMA fight since then but you
know he was an elite kickboxer he was an
elite man he was so good yeah and to see
his shin snap like that he's like God
damn
I mean you would always think about it
before you went to throw a shot you
would always think about the two years
it took you to [__] regrow your bone
back where you could throw kicks with it
again yeah I wouldn't say it slowed my
kicks down checks have done that enough
you know what I mean checks hurt hurt
enough or deterred enough but uh
and yeah it definitely give you
something to think about you know it's
definitely it's the most one of the most
horrific injuries in the sport yeah that
that chin injury and it's happened so
there's so many versions of it now on
Instagram yeah find somebody you see a
small shows where guys are doing it
accidentally breaking their legs I think
nogara uh getting his arms as well that
was horrible I saw another girl get her
arm snapped in a jiu jitsu tournament
yeah same thing oh God damn it tap I
remember when uh khabib had Michael
Johnson and I remember thinking just
please tap please top please tap just
please tap don't make me see this man
don't make me see this tap he got you
fight another day please tap please tap
that [__] spiral arm fracture from
that Kimura is so nasty yeah oh and I
hear those are from from doctors I hear
those are really hard to uh to hear and
stuff yeah hard to repair you know who
knows if your arm's ever going to be the
same again yeah that's a rough one to
come back from
my friend Tom broke his arm playing
basketball like what was it like two
years ago Jamie two years ago it's still
[__] he's still strong he's humorous
or what part did he break he broke the
top everything he broke the top bone
like up here oh that's a humorous yeah
it was big yeah big fracture yeah that
nerve damage in his hand I can imagine
that one being painful because this not
only is the break yeah painful but you
got the weight of the arm uh-huh pulling
on that thing yeah and that could make
it hard for it to heal as well yeah dude
injuries yeah what's the worst injury
you've had in MMA in MMA I've talked
well I hadn't I didn't
in my MMA career I've torn my PEC
training you know what I mean I think
the worst one I had in competition I
mean I broken my hand in competition did
you tear your pack in drilling or
sparring it was just V we were
initiating a warm-up so it was a warm-up
roll me and Ben was like a warm-up roll
and I was passing his guard and then
Henderson Ben Henderson yeah yeah and he
uh shout out to the lab yep oh yeah all
day long lab all day you all know that
everybody knows what what we do so uh
it's a great great gym it really is yeah
that's the whole reason why I quit my
six figure job and moved moved to
Phoenix Arizona yeah
but yeah uh he had a wizard on my left
arm and I was passing to the right side
so I cleared the I cleared his leg and
uh I went to pass his garden I went to I
was extended with my left arm because he
had the Wizard and I went to get strong
to collect him up at the side control
and as soon as I contracted that pick
and tore just like that little three
little rips
and it tore um that was February I think
that was during the that was five week
for
Jon Jones versus who did his last
fighter like heavyweight Dominic Reyes
Dominic brass yeah so that happened in
Houston at the hotel wow and then I came
back and fought
yeah that was 2020 before covet and then
I came back and fought Robert Whittaker
and Abu Dhabi was it still [__] up no
the peck was fine okay shout out to
Aaron's Physical Therapy uh now you got
me running all my Shadows now shout out
there Physical Therapy I've been hitting
them up since uh
the Anderson Silva fight you know what I
mean I've been working out with them
working out there as well as working out
at the lab those two combined if you see
you guys see my cardio those two
combined has really uh propelled my
career but uh I came back after the
packed here to fight Robert Whittaker
and look not not admitted into the fight
he throws his patented Reaper combo one
two head kick and breaks my uh left ulna
oh man so
I ended up fighting this guy for what
another
two rounds plus four minutes of the
first round with a broken owner and uh
I almost got him too he's
the other guy right that's one of those
crazy freak injuries that like it can
always happen when you're blocking kicks
but it was my fault I extended my arm to
block more reactionary as opposed to
being grounded and prepared and bracing
and you know ready to absorb the kick oh
[__] okay right and uh the reason being
because I was slipping his his
initiation typical [__] we all see it
happening all day all day long with
Robert Whittaker we all know that
combination and